IN THE SOUTH CAROLINA PRIMARY ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COUNTRY,
WITH THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR IS
TRYING TO HOLD OFF A
HARD-CHARGING BUSINESSMAN WHO
WAS A COMPLETE UNKNOWN IN THE
STATE SIX MONTHS AGO AND HE'S
GETTING SOME HELP.
CORRESPONDENT JONATHAN SERRIE
LOOKS AT THAT PLACE TONIGHT FROM
COLUMBIA.
>> SOUTH CAROLINA GOVERNOR HENRY
McMASTER CAST HIS BALLOT THIS
GREENVILLE.
SOUTH CAROLINA'S G.O.P. RUNOFF
FOR GOVERNOR CALL THEMSELVES
TRUMP CONSERVATIVES BUT IT WAS
McMASTER THE PRESIDENT CAME TO
STUMP FOR.
>> RIGHT FROM DAY ONE WHEN I
CAME DOWN HERE, HENRY McMASTER
McMASTER, HE SAID WHY ARE YOU
WITH ME?
HIS EARLY SUPPORTERS MR. TRUMP
RALLIED A PACKED ROOM AT THE
McMASTER EVENT.
MANY IN THE CROWD WERE THERE TO
SEE THE PRESIDENT MORE THAN A
CANDIDATE AND MORE IN HOPES MANY
OF THEM WILL VOTE FOR HIM.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS A PLUNGE OF
SUPPORT IN SOUTH CAROLINA, MY
SUPPORTERS ARE HIS SUPPORTERS.
THIS IS NOT A REFERENDUM ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THIS IS A
REFERENDUM ON HENRY McMASTER'S
FAILED LEADERSHIP IN MY VISION
OF CONSERVATIVE REFORM
THROUGHOUT OUR STATES.
COUNTING HIS STATUS AS A
POLITICAL NEWCOMER PROMISING TO
DRAIN THE SWAMP IN THE STATE
CAPITAL.
COMING FROM A SOCIALLY
CONSERVATIVE UPSTATE REGION MAY
PLAY WELL.
JOINED THE ADMINISTRATION AS
HAVE MOVED INTO HIS STATE DURING
HIS BRIEF TENURE AS GOVERNOR.
>> A GREAT TEAM TO GO FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE TO THE STATE HOUSE
TO YOUR HOUSE AND THE PEOPLE IN
SOUTH CAROLINA KNOW THAT WE ARE
ON THE WAY UP, THINGS ARE
GETTING BETTER AND WE WANT TO
KEEP THIS TEAM TOGETHER.
>> THE WINNER OF TONIGHT'S
G.O.P. PRIMARY RUNOFF WILL FACE
DEMOCRAT JAMES SMITH AND THE
GENERAL ELECTION.
SMITH WHO IS BOTH A LAWYER AND A
STATE REPRESENTATIVE HOPES THAT
HIS EXPERIENCE AS A COMBAT VET
WILL HAVE BROAD APPEAL IN THIS